Adam Hawk shield who writes about
slavery in the late seventeen and
eighteen hundreds in the book burry the
chains the February bombing of a major
Shia shrine in the Iraqi town of Samara
has set off a wave of sectarian violence
Sunday on book TV Brandeis University
professor Yitzhak Nakash examines the
rising influences of the Shia in the
Arab world his new book is reaching for
power watch tomorrow at 5 p.m. Eastern
Ben Shapiro is the author of brainwashed
our universities indoctrinate America's
youth you're currently a student at
Harvard Law and recent graduate of UCLA
what did you find on college campuses
what have you found about the the
political culture there I mean it's it's
very clearly an extremely liberal
environment I mean every poll shows the
incredible imbalance that you have
between liberals and conservatives on
campus what I found is that most
students are apathetic they really don't
care about politics at all so the
problem in terms of indoctrination is
really for the apathetic students I've
never claimed the Conservatives are the
ones who are experiencing you know sort
of horrific oppression on campus I don't
think that's necessarily true
I think reports of people being graded
down for their conservative viewpoints
are probably exaggerated to a certain
extent what I can say is that people who
are unaffiliated who don't know that
much about politics are gonna come out
left and they're gonna come out left
specifically because they're hearing a
lot of leftist bias from the professor's
not that the professors are saying stuff
like you know Bush is an idiot or bush
should be impeached or any of that sort
of stuff more because they have control
over the syllabus so they get to control
you know what students see in here on a
given issue and that being the case that
means that the case is going to be
biased to one side inherently did you
come across any statistics in doing your
research about the political
affiliations of
oh yeah I mean there have been a number
of polls there most recently there was a
poll that came out last year that showed
that I believe it was 77% of the
professorial
is registered Democrat or votes Democrat
and that seems a bit low to me I mean if
you look in the Ivy League's furnaces in
the 2000 election 84 percent of
professors voted for Al Gore I mean the
country split 50-50 you have a maybe
four percent of Ivy League professors
voting for Al Gore in Princeton on
specific issues like abortion there been
polls there show 99 percent of Ivy
League professors are pro-choice I mean
that's that's about as imbalanced as you
can possibly get to the claim that and
professors can separate themselves from
their own political bias as long enough
to teach you class I just think it's
awesome why do you think that most
professors are liberal I think there are
a couple reasons the first reason is
self selection I mean I think that you
don't see a lot of liberals working at
the NRA you don't see a lot of
conservatives working in academia it's a
liberal environment and if I'm a
conservative I don't feel like going
into the environment and into half I
mean it's fun to do it for me in college
it's fun in law school but I'm not sure
I'd want to do it as career the the
other reason is that in order to become
a professor you do have to go through a
certain process and that process is run
by liberals so if you have tenured
professors deciding who's to become a
professor if they're the ones who are
reading the papers that professors have
to write more and become professors that
they're doing the hiring then they're
going to be biased in a certain way now
it may not be conscious I think that
probably they would think of themselves
as relatively unbiased when it comes to
figuring out who's a good teacher is not
the problem is that a lot of professors
because they're in ivory tower they
don't even recognize that the other
perspective has fluidity and that being
the case they really believe that what
they're saying is pure fact so anything
else must necessarily be falsehood
there's no reason to get false in a
place in the classroom why do you think
there aren't more conservative colleges
that's a good question I think mostly
because state-sponsored colleges tend to
be very liberal and most a lot of
students go to state-sponsored colleges
I end of brainwashed I I push for a
start up colleges essentially from
conservatives there's an attempt in
Colorado to put together a Reagan
college that fell apart I think part of
it is that if you're an alumni
regardless of whether you're
conservative or liberal
you have a stake in keeping your
school's reputation as high as possible
because then you get to brag about
spending of money to Princeton from
Harvard you can give money to Harvard
regardless of what's going on on the
campus so there's no real reason for
colleges to change their policy they're
getting a lot of money the alumni are
gonna continue giving money because it's
good for their resume for people to look
at their college and today well you know
you went to Harvard even if they don't
agree with the current political policy
at Harvard so if there's no market for
it then and you are unwilling to go out
of their way to create a market for
conservative colleges there's not what's
your personal experience been at Harvard
Law School do you speak up when you
disagree with what a professor says
about politics yeah dude it's a lot of
fun
I think they conservatives need to
engage professors I mean one thing
concerns some concerning students don't
tend to do is realized when professors
just want to talk and just said that you
know just sit there listen once to talk
but no but I found a lot that's been
very receptive to the argument they
think it's a lot of fun so